Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 13th,
2015 what's going on?
How I,
yeah,
I just had a really embarrassing moment,
right?
It's Sunday afternoon.
Isn't there a song about Sunday afternoons?
Rainy days and Mondays.
Oh,
Jesus.
Sunday afternoon is now.
It goes,
no,
the,
um,
I just had a really embarrassing thing.
I fucking Andrew who sends me all the podcast Shit
and walking my dog around the block might Butoh the little dude and he tells me
to call him,
so I call him.
So he tells me that he's sending me the podcast shit.
So I go to it,
you know,
I come back with the dog and I go to fucking check my emails and it's not there.
In fact,
I haven't got one fucking emails since July 10th,
which never happens.
So I checked my little mini iPad thing.
It won't let,
it's refreshing.
It won't give me anything else that checked my fucking iPhone.
I got the six now.
Just like all you kids out there playing the fucking Avatar Games,
the one single person,
first person,
uh,
I'll blow your fucking face off in the comfort of my a attic bedroom.
All right.
I got,
I got the new one.
None of them,
no emails for two days.
So I'm like,
what the fuck?
This fucking happens to me all the time,
so I lose my shit,
uh,
calling Andrew up and he's going,
that's weird.
That's strange.
I never heard of that allies is that people always say about my shit.
And then he tells me he hasn't told us he hasn't sent it yet.
Let me try sending them.
And then they came through.
So there was nothing wrong.
Yeah,
it was just my dumb ass had not got an email in two days and I thought I was so
fucking important that I at least get a little bit of spam.
Okay.
So is so whatever,
this fucking egg and old freckles face here,
you know some,
I'm starting off humble.
Yeah.
Starting off humble,
like dead fucking Irish guy there with his chest tattoo,
running around,
talking all this shit that he was going to do to the half of the fucking world.
Now listen,
I don't watch a lot of UFC so I don't even know any of the fucking names,
but I watched that,
you know,
and I'm part Irish and that guy skipping around like a fucking Leprechaun,
talking all that shit.
It just fucking annoyed me.
So now I'm,
I'm now I'm rooting for Barney rubble and Latino Barney rubble.
That Mendez Dude,
right and fucking,
uh,
what,
what this face there who looks like he looks like a,
he looks like a combination of uh,
the guy from the spin doctors and uh,
that creepy mascot for Burger King.
I can't figure out what he is except we can fucking spin around and put his heel
and your temple.
All right.
So I'm watching this shit and he's talking all this shit and he's doing all that
Roy Jones like,
I'm going to humiliate you while I beat you.
And a,
which is course is making me root for the little fella.
I mean,
who do I see in there?
Even though that guy's a pasty fuck with red hair,
just like me,
he's actually got a full head of hair.
The son of a bitch,
right?
Um,
I want a root form.
You know what?
I make little fucking redhead solidarity.
I want a roof with this guy,
but he's such a cunt.
And the first,
halfway through the first round,
I'm like,
you know what?
Fuck this guy.
Let's go show,
right.
I'm room full of little guy.
Little guys fucking starts taking them to the mat.
He's fucking throwing elbows.
This fucking little fucking burger king guy is eating these things and then he
gets up and he kind of nods like,
Oh yeah,
that was pretty good.
That was pretty good.
Pretty good.
You got to cut over your eye.
They're freckles,
right?
Next thing you know,
next round comes out.
Yeah,
no fucking little guy.
He's putting this freckled comment on his back ground and pound grounded and
ground and pound.
Okay.
And fucking a Ireland's burger king guy gets back up.
Yeah.
He gets back up and all of a sudden he's not talking shit anymore.
He's got a little fucking,
I was pretty good.
It was pretty good.
Pretty good.
He was on top of you the whole fucking round.
Long story short,
I think it was the third round.
He fucking does it again.
He's just on top of this guy beating his fucking ass.
All right.
He gets up.
Okay.
You know,
which is good on the fucking red headed dude.
He fucking gets up,
Connor,
whatever.
Mcglaughlin or was it Sarah McLaughlin?
I don't want to fuck his name.
Is Connor something or other,
right.
He fucking gets up and uh,
the,
the little guys gassed,
the guy got two weeks' notice.
This other fuck's been training for months to fight this Jose,
Josie,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Right.
So a little fellas gassed.
He catches a fucking left.
He goes down,
he's covered up.
He's not fighting back,
but he's covering up and immediately the fucking dude stuff.
I'd say I had to knock it off.
That'll be it.
And then the spine doctors guy jumps up and down,
you know,
jumps on the fucking cage.
You know,
it starts crying into the Irish Ireland flag.
Okay?
Okay.
Now I'm not saying that that fucking hires,
dude's not a bad ass fighter.
I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying that little fellow,
he earned the right.
He earned the right to ride out that round,
get to the chair,
and then you look at them,
you want to go out again.
Granted he was gassed.
Maybe they saved him,
but you know,
I don't know.
I don't know shit about the sport.
I don't even know the fucking names,
but all I can tell you was that evidently that was going to be a big fight.
You know when mayor mccheese there was going to fight Josie and the pussy,
whatever the fuck his name is,
right?
That's why the fight gay man,
I'm telling you right now,
anybody who who,
who is the Don King of the sport,
you should fucking,
you should have to dress like boss hog because to me,
that fucking reeked of a quick stoppage.
You can't tell me this is [inaudible].
Of course you can tell me the fuck do I know I'm just a comedian.
Right.
And I play one on TV too.
That just reeked of Holy Fuck.
We thought he was going to beat this little bastards ass and we're going to get
a two for one on the paper view here because everybody,
you know the Irish guy talks so much shit.
You're going to watch him anyways.
Right?
I know.
I sound like a moron.
Fuck Yo.
And it seemed like bullshit to me.
It just seemed like bullshit or maybe I've watched rocky too many times.
I wanted that little fella to fuck the whole thing up.
I wanted him to fuck up the big payday and it didn't happen.
Okay.
Hat's off to the Irish guy.
All right.
Double hats off cause he's also redhead,
you know,
he's making us look good.
God knows we'd take a bunch of shit.
I just thought it was a quick stoppage and good on him that he took that
pounding and was able to get back up again.
But I'll tell you right now,
that was not a good fight for that guy.
I would guess because I would think that the other guy would be like,
oh,
that's very interesting.
It's very interesting what that little fella there did on only fucking two weeks
training.
Isn't it amazing how much shit I'm giving to people who in this sleep?
Like walking in there,
sleep could fucking choke me up the second I brushed up against them with any
sort of energy that they didn't like.
You know,
is it still muttering in this sleep about fucking a bullet.
Cornflakes stayed still choke me out.
Doesn't stop me from talking shit like the bitch that I am in my own podcast and
the safety of my own,
uh,
my own,
office within my house.
Oh yeah.
I'll fucking talk shit about anybody in here.
You get me outside the confines of my gate.
Hey,
how are you?
Nice to see you.
I like your shirt.
Um,
anyways,
it was a great,
what a fucking,
if you didn't rent it,
man,
I would rent that shit.
UFC one 89 for as much as I'm being a little fucking rag and contour just wire
to wire.
Every fight was a fucking knockout.
Was unbelievable.
You know,
my favorite part of the night was when Rogan was watching whatever fight it was
where,
uh,
I don't fucking know this white dude was fighting this other guy and the guy's
just swinging wildly and,
and uh,
Rogan actually laughed at one point,
you know,
not like,
no disrespect to the fight or he just was enjoying the fight and he sort of
laughed and said,
this is a bar fight.
And,
uh,
this fucking maniac,
you know,
a lot of fighters,
after they win the fight,
when they're celebrating,
they look scary.
But the second they start talking this to totally chill,
there's a few of them that can't shut it off.
And you're like,
that guy,
you know,
like that big dude and the dirty dozen posey remember that?
Come on Posey,
stick them,
stack them.
Yeah,
yeah,
I'm pushing you.
And he's fucking Lee Marvins pushing him.
Then he just fucking snaps.
And he said,
so I stop,
push and he can't fucking shut it off.
And he wants to drive fucking Lee Marvins knows right through his brain and keep
punching until he fucking goes is his fist.
And his forum goes right through the brains of his entire fucking family tree.
Like that guy had like that energy.
Yeah,
they,
there was so many sick.
I just really should know these fighters names,
especially considering I'm trying to get in shape and these guys are in some of
the best shape he could possibly be.
And um,
I dunno,
I'm not gonna pretend like I know anything about the sport.
All I can tell you was I 100% got my fucking money's worth.
And uh,
other than I just thought they stopped the fight a little too soon,
but really thinking about it,
I think I was just being selfish because I wanted that little dude to upset him.
I got to stop calling little dude.
The guy was shorter than the fucking record.
Um,
he fucking,
I just,
I thought he earned the right to get to the fucking corner and be like,
dude,
can you go,
are you gassed or whatever.
But then of course he's gonna say,
yeah,
I can go on.
Then maybe he would actually really get fucked up.
You know,
you know bill,
maybe if you think about it,
maybe the official referee
of that paper view fight maybe knows a little bit more.
Maybe it was a little bit closer,
maybe has watched a few more fights than you did and maybe he stopped it at the
right time.
Ah,
write whatever I wanted to see it keep going.
I want to see him put him on his back again.
Okay.
God dammit.
I love when that happens.
I love when an underdog fucks.
Like some dude comes in,
he's not supposed to fight this guy or it's just supposed to be this tune up,
fight for the big fucking payday and this guy comes in and just fucking knocks
him out.
Knocked the dude out.
I always imagined like that would be that.
That's what it would be like if you somehow interrupted like the new world
order.
You know,
and I'm not saying that this shape shifters,
but I'm saying if he,
if you honestly think that these fucking maniacs,
that there's not a group of people that want to run it all and own it all,
then I,
I dunno,
I dunno then I wish I was you.
I wish I lived where you lived and saw what you saw that you,
you haven't seen that fucking human behavior.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm out of my phone and I go,
fuck yourself.
It's a Sunday afternoon.
I'm hanging out by myself.
My wife's not around.
I've been talking to my dog all day.
Did you,
do you think that this is gonna make sense?
Well done.
Um,
well did you,
I should have yelled.
Um,
anyways,
but,
uh,
and the next UFC I go in and out of the UFC,
you know what I mean?
Like I do with like wrestling when they don't have a lot of good stars or
whatever,
I start to fade or whatever.
I get busy and my fucking life I should watch it because whenever I watch it,
it motivates me to get in shape.
You know what I mean?
Or if I even watched like the ultimate fighter,
which I know that's kind of like making the band,
uh,
or who wants to be a millionaire for like fucking fighters.
You know what I mean?
I don't know how many guys actually came out of that fucking that went on to do
some shit.
You know?
I think most of them are like,
you know those people that sing during the first week of American idol and all
those people,
Jimmy crack card and I are I buddy,
you're not going to Vegas.
And then they cried to the camera.
At least I do it.
You know,
I carrier I truths about the cuts.
You know what I mean?
Most of them end up like that.
And as always,
even that crying little fucking Douche bag could kick the shit out of me and
asleep.
I had met all of that before.
No,
you can't come at me like,
oh well maybe you want to talk shit about,
show me you can help you beat the fight.
Maybe you should go fuck yourself.
He says in the safety of his own office,
within his house,
behind his gait.
Um,
so anyways,
the next UFC,
which I,
I'm going to go out on a limb and say it's going to be UFC,
uh,
one 90.
Okay.
Um,
the constipation or whatever they've kind of out of adjectives.
I think they finally stopped doing that.
Remember that the revenge factor then it was like a deportation,
um,
canceled reservation,
UFC one 43.
They just ran out.
So they just haven't,
they just call them by numbers now.
So I think one 90 is going to be,
that's going to be down in Brazil,
the beginning of August.
And what's great is a rowdy Ronda Rousey.
Uh,
I hope I seven.
Is it Rhonda?
Rhonda Rousey?
How do I not remember names?
Once again,
someone else who kicked the shit out of me in her sleep.
Um,
she's fighting,
she's fighting in Brazil and she's fighting the top woman in Brazil.
And what's great about that is I just,
that's going to be so great to watch her shot an entire nation down.
You know,
I think the biggest problem,
she's going to have his security trying to get the fuck outta there after she
beats that woman's ass because I think she's gonna end.
You know why?
Because I watched about 0.8 seconds of highlights on,
on her opponent.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
I'm talking about the fight game.
I'm in way over my head.
Fuck you.
It's the dog days of summer.
Hockey's over.
Basketball is over.
There's no football.
What do you want from me?
The fuck do you want from me?
So I don't know.
Anything can happen is what I've learned.
Watching fights or whatever.
And I know that Brazilian girl,
she's got one of those Brazilian booty,
so who knows?
If she gets low,
she gets slow.
Who knows what can happen,
you know what I mean?
She puts that thing to fucking work.
Who knows?
Um,
but I don't think it's going to happen.
anyways.
Yeah,
the dog days of summer.
So I watched a,
I missed them.
The men's final was today.
As I said,
I'm taping here on a Sunday.
Um,
congratulations to a Djokovich,
you know,
coming back after you lose in the French Open,
he beat Andy Federer.
I would have liked to have seen that.
Maybe they'll replay it on the tennis channel,
watched the replays,
Serena winning the Serena Slam,
you know,
she won last year's us open,
then she won the Australia,
and then she won the French and now she won Wimbledon.
So she wanted the last four in a row.
And who's getting knows she'll win the fucking USL.
But uh,
and the record is six,
I believe by Martina net that travel,
Lola,
um,
I think and um,
by going like glanced at Wikipedia for two seconds.
I have no idea.
But,
uh,
I'm rooting for her.
She needs one more to tie Steffi Graf and obviously one more after that and
she'll have one the most ever,
which is pretty amazing that not only she could do that,
but she could do it at her age.
Um,
Ge built that was very informative.
It wasn't funny on any fucking level.
Our right.
Relax.
Okay.
So as I mentioned last week,
oh,
freckles.
All freckles is on the wagon.
Show me the way to go home.
Boom,
boom.
I'm tired and I won't,
I'll go to bed.
Um,
I've been on the wagon now for seven days,
no booze.
And um,
I was,
uh,
like a buck 81,
86.6 my way and I wanted to lose three pounds a week for the next like two
months to get myself down to my fighting weight.
And I got on the scale this afternoon and I was one 83.2,
so I actually lost 3.4 pounds.
So next week,
you know,
I need to be down to one 80.
So if you want to do it with me,
this is what I'm doing.
This is my diet,
this works,
this what's works from me and what I'm doing.
I wake up in the morning,
I take my dog,
Oh,
I take my dog for like an hour long hike and a,
I come back and then I,
um,
I have oatmeal and a banana and then between lunch and uh,
in breakfast I either have an apple or an orange.
And so I get two helpings of fruit before 12.
After 12.
If I'm going to have,
I'll only have a vegetable,
I won't have a fruit just because it's got all this sugar.
So then for lunch,
as you can tell,
this is not an exciting die.
And as you can tell by the incredible lack of passion in my voice,
but it's working for me.
You know,
as Whitney and Bobby Brown used to say,
it works.
It works for me.
It works.
Sorry,
I have a black wife,
so I see stuff like that on TV.
my wife is black,
African American.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
anybody remember that episode?
Whitney and Bobby Brown.
It's kind of tragic now obviously.
Really you think so?
Bill said daughters in a coma,
um,
when they were fucking in the store and they were trying to enhance or
something,
sunglasses and they were both probably high and they go and does it work?
It works.
And then they just started doing this song.
It works for me.
It works doing this fucking dance and everyone's staring at him.
I was actually a nice moment
anyways.
Uh,
what was I talking about?
Oh yeah.
So,
and then in the afternoon,
um,
what do I usually have in the afternoon?
That's kind of whatever.
I don't know.
That's,
that's a little weird.
The afternoon one.
The fuck do I usually have,
I tried to have something healthy that's usually,
I'll have like a bowl of cereal,
just something,
something to throw a little flare into the day.
But then at night I go,
uh,
I eat super healthy right around between five and six,
you know,
protein,
the size of the palm of your hand and then just a bunch of vegetables.
And then I just crushed fucking waters for the rest of the night.
Um,
and I'm not drinking anything else but water to be honest with Ya.
And uh,
and then if I do get hungry at night and I need a late night snack,
I have a bunch of celery sticks already cut up and I'll take like a fucking,
like a spoonful of peanut butter.
I know,
but you know what?
It works.
Fucking fucking I only got gotta do is just live like this for three fucking
months and I can get down to my fighting weight,
not three months,
two months.
And uh,
yeah,
do it with me.
Eight Times three,
that's 20 of,
you'll lose 24 pounds with me.
All right.
Do it with me.
Get you a beach body like me in September.
So anyways,
you don't even have to do this shit.
I'm just telling you guys that I'm going to do it.
So I stay off the,
I stay on the wagon,
Freudian slip there,
stay on the wagon.
And then I also continued to drop my three pounds a week.
Um,
whatever man.
You know what I mean?
Next week we'll be six pounds and in between week two and three,
that's when people start noticing which motivates you even more so,
uh,
you know,
Jesus.
And then I just spent doing like the pushups and the pull ups and that type of
thing.
Um,
Bert Kreischer sent me this thing on Twitter about how to improve your grip
strength,
this men's health thing.
In the first exercise I've actually been able to,
I got myself worked up that I can do is basically you hang from a chin up bar a
three sets of one minute,
um,
which you wouldn't think it's hard,
but it is.
It can be at whatever.
If you're a fat fuck,
like I am.
Oh God,
I hate myself right now.
Um,
so that's what I'm doing.
I'm eating right and I'm watching the UFC and watching boxing.
I'm just looking at people in shape,
you know what I mean?
If you're a fat fuck,
watch men that are in shape with your wife and you'll feel it on.
I like God,
I wish my husband looked like that and I'm telling you,
it'll motivate you to get down there and get on a fucking Matt.
Um,
so anyways,
hey,
listen,
I got an idea here.
I know when I promote this right now.
So,
you know,
I sell these posters on the road and uh,
I'd come home and I'll,
I'll have some extra ones and I autographed in my,
send them out,
we shipped them out,
people by him and we ship them out.
So the last time,
um,
we had the ones from the,
uh,
the southern tour and uh,
you know,
we ship those out.
Everybody got their fucking orders,
you know,
no problem.
But it did take longer.
A lot of people were like,
where the fuck is it?
Cause it took us a long time to get them out because we do everything ourselves
here.
So no,
this,
all the posters we have that are left over from my,
uh,
my week in Boston where I did the 19 shows.
MMM.
Those are all autographed and they're already packaged in the tube ready to go.
All we need is for you to order them and um,
we'll just slap a label on them.
And my guy is telling me that these fuckers will be out by,
uh,
by Tuesday.
So they will go on sale.
MMM.
Tonight at 10:00 PM Pacific Time,
which is fucking stupid.
I'm going to,
I got to tweet about it.
Yeah.
MMM.
They're all autographed and whatnot.
And uh,
what else?
All right.
Oh,
well,
see if you don't want to,
if you want to,
um,
send an email to the podcast,
it's bill@themmpodcast.com.
That's where you send it.
And um,
okay,
whatever.
So if you'd like an autographed poster poster from my historic run or stupid
run,
depending on who you are of 19 shows in Boston,
uh,
we had some leftover ones.
We had about,
uh,
about three,
400 of them.
I got them all autographed.
They make a great gift for someone that you like or maybe don't give a fuck
about the 20 bucks plus the shipping.
You can order them right off my website,
[inaudible] dot com just click click on the merchant page.
And,
uh,
like I said,
we already got them all boxed up or tubed up,
whatever you're supposed to say,
and they're ready to go.
So if you want one,
uh,
I would appreciate it buying it.
It's not,
I get it.
Um,
so anyways,
anyways,
what else did I want to talk about?
I'm going through here.
Oh,
thank you to everybody that's sent me in all the information about the Ford
galaxies.
I should've mentioned that I wanted a two door and I believe I said 65 or 66.
A lot of people sent me shit from 63 64 68.
That was still cool.
67 cause I got to learn how the car has changed.
But um,
um,
two of them were really what I wanted and I called both and they were already
gone.
So,
um,
I think once a month I'll put the word out to you guys and I'll keep looking for
it.
But uh,
you know,
I don't know,
didn't work out this week.
What are you gonna do?
I already got my truck,
my trucks go on my,
it's not starting well,
I figured out what the antifreeze thing was.
I had it parked on this really steep hill and just cause it's fucking old.
It doesn't have any stop.
I Dunno,
something to block the fuck antifreeze just started dribbling out overnight.
So it wasn't even that much.
But uh,
there's been no antifreeze not eat anything that's dripped out since then.
And if you saw the amount that was there in the morning,
you would think I had a major problem.
Um,
and nothing has happened ever since then.
And yes,
thank you to everybody out there who told me to check the radiator to make sure
he had enough antifreeze.
I did do that,
but I appreciate you letting me know anyways.
And uh,
so everything's all good with that.
And I fucking love driving the truck,
so,
so there you go.
So,
so here we go.
Um,
let's see.
What am I going to talk about it?
She said the whole fucking podcasts just fell up.
That's why you don't do those announcements in the middle of it.
It kills my whole,
my whole fucking whatever.
Oh,
I didn't mention you don't want to eat dinner.
I,
I basically,
I dunno,
I eat steak or a chicken.
I try to stay away from fish unless it's like salmon and I only eat salmon
because we can,
we grow it ourselves in a fucking petri dish.
And even though it might cause cancer someday,
I don't think I'm more important than all the fish in the fucking ocean.
So I'm going to roll the dice that that genetically altered fucked up salmon
that I'm eating is not as bad as it probably is.
But,
um,
you know,
I was watching shark week this week on the discovery channel and those guys have
got to give it up to discovery channel.
They've come a long way on way they own the way that they depict sharks,
but they still always have like that jaws fucking vibe to it.
And I really,
it's fucking reprehensible that they do it.
But at the end of the day,
you know what,
they're not scientists.
They're a fucking network and they don't give a fuck about nature.
You know what I mean?
They always got to do that shit.
Like,
like the shark has some personal vendetta,
like in all those jaws movies,
like after,
like after they fought off the shark,
they start driving away,
you know,
when the boat that,
whatever you do sailing away what it does,
no sale I guess should drive away,
right.
Whatever the fuck they're doing.
And then the shark follows them.
Like the sharks,
I call these,
you motherfuckers think that shit is over,
right?
Like it wants to kill these fucking people.
Um,
but then again it's just a movie.
You would think that the discovery channel wouldn't have that they had this
fucking one.
Right.
You know,
and I always watched the first three quarters because once they start going to
the end,
they start showing what we're doing and how many sharks were killing and it
will,
how bad we're fucking up the ocean.
Like I saw something on the discovery channel with his scientist was going at
this fish market in a,
somewhere in like Southeast Asia and he just,
he goes once she just mentally get past all the mount sheer amount of,
of dead fish there that are being consumed every fucking day.
What he,
he's looking,
what he's looking at is the different species and what he's finding is he seeing
species of fish that you never saw in a fish market anymore.
And that's because they used to drag the nets,
you know,
up at the surface.
And now because that's basically been fished out,
we are now like,
I don't know how many feet down.
It was some
level of,
of
whatever the fuck it was.
How many?
600 feet,
500 feet.
I don't what the fuck we were,
but it sent chills down my spine like what the fuck are we doing and why isn't
anybody talking about it in political office?
Right.
They,
so they were dragging up species of fish that you just never seen a fish market.
Just for the simple fact.
They never dragged the nets down that low.
And uh,
there's a couple of fucked up look and sharks and like,
do you know those fish that you know,
you start getting so fucking low,
you know,
they have an eyes.
Isn't that important?
Finding some really fucked up look and stuff like you.
Like is that from this planet?
I've never seen one of those before.
So I'm trying to lay off Sushi and I'm trying to lay off all that stuff.
So I've,
I've dropped that down and I did.
A lot of my friends are telling me that the bison and that type of shit,
anything that we,
I'm going to just try to eat shit that we,
um,
like pigs,
cows,
chickens,
even though I know they're not fucking healthy.
But I mean,
at least we're reproducing that shit and considering where the ones that have
fucking it up anyways,
shouldn't I be the one that eats it?
You know,
you shouldn't,
I die rather than a bunch of fucking fish.
I Dunno.
I watching that shit and going on that debt bus tour I took through California,
right.
Fucking hilarious.
Me and Joe Barden or going to a giant bus just tearing up the fucking
atmosphere.
Such a hypocrite,
you know,
but I'm cutting down on the fish,
dude.
I'm just seeing how low the water is out here.
It's a,
it's a fucking,
you know,
it's getting there,
dude.
It's slow down even slowly.
It's fucking getting crazy out there.
So,
um,
I dunno,
the one exciting thing I heard about the weather out here is they might have an
El Nino,
so it would actually give us some rain,
not nearly enough as we need,
but at least some fucking rain.
So a,
I'm really hoping for that.
I'm hoping that's going to happen for the next four fucking years in a row
because a,
I dunno,
going over the,
uh,
the Hoover and seeing how low the fucking water was was pretty scary.
Why do you need to hear about this?
You don't need to fucking hear about it.
Right?
What do I Bamani out to beginning of Gi bill?
Really?
Is The fucking world going to hell in a handbasket we'd get it.
Um,
okay.
So anyways,
I watched a little bit of the Yankees Red Sox today cause I miss the men's final
and it was fucking nothing else on.
And um,
I gotta be honest,
Dude.
You know,
I don't think other than put Detroit or teas and Zander bogarts I don't know
anybody on our fucking team.
Um,
except that guy from the outfield,
Shane Victorino,
I guess I know four guys.
Yeah,
I didn't know any Yankees and it was really weird to see it looked like Alfonso
Soriano which short?
Um,
I dunno,
they kind of looked like the Yankees looked like the,
the like the Dave Righetti Yankees to me.
And um,
I don't know the red sox stuff like the fucking 88 red sox to me it's really
sort of a weird time.
But I watched a couple of headings,
you know,
we were down to nothing.
We went up three to two.
I made an effort.
I made it an effort.
Um,
so next week I fly up to the Montreal comedy festival.
I'm doing a Blues Festival in Ottawa.
If you want to get tickets,
just go to [inaudible] dot com and then,
uh,
I'm doing two shows in Montreal.
Yeah,
I'm going up there.
I'm going to have a good fucking time.
Um,
and as a trash my Bruins for not making the playoffs.
All I gotta say is,
and how did you guys do?
Oh,
we made the playoffs.
did ya?
Did you win the cup?
Yeah,
that's what I thought.
I'm 22 years and counting of the fucking,
this is the longest drought in Montreal,
Canadian history.
And I am enjoying every fucking day of it,
every fucking day of it.
Um,
and you know who's getting hit with the Bruins?
I don't know what we're going to do next year.
I have no fucking idea how you replaced Lucida.
What do you do?
You sign some fucking goon from Philly that that's supposed to fill the void.
Um,
I dunno.
I'm still fucking shell shocked with the Bruins.
Did we fucking do that shit every,
every fucking time?
Somebody will,
you know,
they wanted to know.
You can't trick you,
punch you months.
Some point you got to pay.
Somebody's got to get in.
Had a fuck.
Do you get rid of Lou Cheech?
Everybody had a bad year.
He under fucking produced.
Maybe you guys didn't put the right team on the fucking ice.
What's he supposed he supposed to do?
All of it.
All right.
What am I doing?
I'm yelling at my own fucking team here anyways.
Um,
so yeah,
so I'm doing two shows up in Montreal,
um,
Wednesday and Thursday of next week.
So that would be 15 and set to 22nd and the 23rd.
I'm doing shows at a theater up there.
I think if they're not sold out,
they're close to being sold out.
But if you'd like to watch me play drums when I'm up there Monday,
Tuesday and Thursday,
the seven o'clock show,
the goddamn comedy jam,
I am going to be up there.
Um,
playing a song each night,
having a great time telling stories about,
uh,
my failed drumming career and all the,
all the awful fucking,
I,
it wasn't even ever even in a band.
I never even got my drums out of my basement.
My people used to just come over and we will play.
And uh,
you know,
I was always the worst fucking guy,
so I get plenty of funny stories to tell about that shit.
So,
um,
anyways,
let's,
let's get to some of the fucking questions here for,
Oh,
you know what?
I haven't done the fucking advertising for this week.
You know,
Jesus,
Jeez,
where are we?
Come on,
Bill,
for fuck sakes.
Can you for once in your life,
learn on a computer works.
All right.
Draft kings,
everybody.
Draftkings how long before these guys are on real sports?
Are you worried that you ruin people's lives?
Um,
draft kings.
Everybody.
Baseball is in full swing.
Yeah.
And you can be part of the action all seasonLong@draftkings.com the official
daily Fantasy Patina of major league baseball.
How,
what the fuck?
How the fuck are you guys partners with them?
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
None of the players gambler gamble.
But let's turn the whole fucking crowd or a bunch of degenerate gamblers.
People.
Please be careful with this site.
Only gamble what you can afford to lose.
Don't buy into their dumb commercials.
We'll put the money down.
Pick a t Lou,
then collect your money like that.
Fucking I,
you guys not.
Come on.
Have you ever watched casino?
Uh,
daily fantasy means no season long commitments.
Just instant cash.
Instant gratification.
Why wait until the end of the season to get paid when you could win huge prizes
every day at draft kings.
It's like a brand new season.
Every time you play,
just pick two pictures right there.
Pick eight position players and pick up your cash.
That's all you gotta do.
Everybody every fucking week.
Quit your day job,
man.
Just pick two pictures,
eight position players and pick up your cash.
Just ask her.
I'd take her to a movie and get your Dick Sucked every fucking time.
That's it.
Hey,
ask Peter from Colorado.
Whoever the fuck that is.
Last year we won $1 million in one day.
Simply playing fantasy baseball@draftkings.com hundreds of thousands of fantasy
sports fans.
Just like you have already cashed in a draft kings.
Are they up lifetime?
Who knows?
Now's your turn.
Call to action.
Nuke a new contest.
Start daily.
So how are we to draft kings.com right now and use the Promo code defense to
play for free and the today's $10,000 fantasy baseball contest.
draftkings.com official partner of major league baseball.
Wow.
And her defense for free entry now,
draftkings.com draftkings.com this draftkings.com I actually liked these guys.
If you don't fucking get in over your head.
I like how you get to put a team together and you get to play commissioner.
Uh,
maybe we'll have your bitch and less about your team.
Like I was about the Bruins.
But please,
please be careful with that thing.
All right?
Don't start doubling down and doing all the dumb shit that you fucking do.
I'm telling you right now that has,
that has Bryant Gumbel written all over it where he then,
you know,
then major league baseball had no comment on it and then somehow he ties it in
with Pete rose.
Where do you draw the line?
All right,
let's get out.
Let's get off my soapbox here.
Okay.
Oh,
Mandy's me undies.
No more sweaty balls,
but dude do do me undies.
Biondi Poland down in a bathroom.
Stall it take us shit.
Ed.
Take a fucking yank 'em up.
You won't miss you.
Balls will be kept in that soft fucking shit.
That's way softer than cotton.
Oh yeah.
Guys.
I can't keep singing this song.
I,
I'm odd things that rhyme with sweaty balls,
balls,
falls,
stalls,
malls
beyond age,
beyond ease.
No more prank calls,
but Oh,
don't do me undies.
Mandy's stick your phone in the right.
Stick your Dick in.
They'll phone.
Uh,
you know that feeling of putting on under old saggy underwear.
You need to know that feeling of great fitting underwear that is two times
softer than cotton.
You need to know about me undies.
Mandy's,
no most sweaty balls.
We really meaning Mian he's has the most comfortable underwear you'll ever try
on and it's insane how good they make your boss feel.
Maybe I should pick a different song.
Fucking me.
Ds Wear Red on my balls.
Yeah.
Again,
I'm up and they are
dry.
They even got them
for your swear
clam.
Put it right there.
Like a Maxi pad head.
No,
it doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
Maybe a spin doctor song and honor with that guy with the chest tattoo.
Um,
what was the spin doctor?
What can you get back to the copy bill?
Um,
been a whole lot easier since my balls have been dry.
Me undies,
it's the most comfortable underwear you will ever try on.
And it's insane how good they may keep balls feel they fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you.
Yeah.
They don't give you a zealot.
He got some invisible bully behind you giving you a Wedgie.
No more turning around,
screaming out in the middle of a meeting and there's nobody there.
And then you don't get a raise.
And they literally pull moisture away from your skin so you stay cool.
Uh,
but they also make you look great.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and check out the photography.
You fucking Weirdo.
And for the girls,
check out those smoking hot boy shorts.
You know every guy's going to go do that.
Stop acting like the women want to do that,
but you have to turn up.
Try them on for yourself.
This quality would typically retail for two times.
To me,
undies,
price.
No retail middleman means more savings for you or more profit for you guys.
God knows you.
Don't open your books here.
We'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] Dot com slash burn get 20% off your first order and a low flat
rate.
International Shipping and low fleet,
low flat rate,
international shipping,
sorry,
save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them or your first pair is free.
Once you feel me undies on your body,
you never going to go back and me.
Andy's isn't just for you guys.
They just launched their,
all of me.
Women's collection of four piece line of undies designed specifically for the
female body and all its complex,
gorgeous as hell.
Glory.
Sorry,
I'm trying to figure out how to read that fucking paragraph.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck and vocal inflection supposed to be anyways,
but to get that 20% off,
you have to go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird that's m e n d.com/ [inaudible]
all right,
what else do we got here?
Oh good.
This is the last one.
Fantastic.
No more reading out loud for freckles legal zone.
There are a lot of great reasons.
Smart business people trust legal zoom for status.
If you want to incorporate form an LLC or a nonprofit file,
a patent or trademark,
get a DBA and more legal zoom provides to help you need over the past decade.
Hi,
do you know me?
I'm Dick Van Patten.
Over the past decade,
more than a million business owners,
just like you have started with legal zone,
but did you know legal zoom is your first stop when you need advice from an
attorney?
Oh yeah.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm.
So they built a network of independent attorneys in most states to provide legal
advice and other useful services to help you run your business.
So whether you need a contract reviewed or advice on whether you should
incorporate or form an LLC,
whatever you illegal question is,
start with legal zoom.
And as always,
they provide complete transparency with upfront pricing,
customer reviews,
and a hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed.
Complete transparency.
Uh,
make the smart choice for your business@legalzoom.com today and don't forget to
enter bur bur are at the checkout to save even more.
Again,
that's Burr at checkout for more savings,
legalzoom,
Promo Code Bar.
Um,
legal help is here.
Ah,
fuck one more.
God dammit.
stamps.com everybody.
Jesus Christ.
Most of us are trying to find more time every day to get things done so you
can't let a trip to the post office stole your down.
Now you don't have to.
Thanks to stamps.com oh by he's a jolly good fellow with stamps.com buy and
print official US postage right from your own computer and printer stamps.com.
We'll send you a digital scale and you can put your fat ass on it and ship
yourself anywhere in the world automatically calculates the exact posted you
need for any letter or package.
Any class of male,
you'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again.
Okay?
Oh,
it's still lovely.
Nia.
I'm doing my podcast right now.
You're on live on a Monday morning podcast.
Oh,
hello?
I've got to put the dog away because you've got a company while I'm sitting in
my underwear in my me undies be on these,
you know what I have are in the office.
Close the door.
All right.
Then you bring the company and at some point bring me a pair of pants.
Bye.
Why?
All right.
Um,
do everything right from your desk with stamps.com print postage you need,
put it on your letter or package and just hand it to your mail carrier,
your mail person,
and you're done.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters when I whore myself out at the end
of my shows.
Right now,
use my last name,
birth for this special offer.
No risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer bonus offer that includes a digital scale
and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstamps.com enter bar.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Thank God that's done day.
Christ that's done.
So,
um,
anyways,
I want to thank everybody for just sending in all these uh oh wait a minute.
These four galaxies.
I got a couple here.
America's dream cars.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
that's the one right there.
Holy Fuck.
That's still one 65 Ford galaxy 502 door runs very well.
That means it's a piece of shit.
Two 89 v eight motor motor,
47,000 miles liar,
automatic transition white with Ivy Interior.
Looks like it's blue to me.
All chrome is with the car.
Oh Jesus.
This is getting bad.
Original chrome rust free frame interior is original and needs to be restored.
This is a North Carolina car in his solid everywhere.
If you're looking for a good drug,
I haven't classic.
Okay.
Price 2,500 bucks.
Jesus Christ.
Can you go wrong?
Oh my God.
That might be the one.
Thank you for every whoever sent me that one.
Um,
all right,
garden.
Oh,
something got cut off here since Thursday.
Podcast bill I'm obsessed with and then it just says t I don't know what you're
obsessed with.
All right,
guard Billy Green thumb.
I think someone uses this before.
I don't think they did.
I was listening to old podcasts.
You were talking about making your,
your makeshift garden out there in Los Los Angeles.
Can we have an update?
Yeah.
The update is we are in a biblical level drought and um,
you know,
I'm not allowed to water my grass and that type of shit.
So,
uh,
you know,
I just water what I have.
I've got a couple of tomato plants.
I got a lemon and lime tree.
Do you believe I've got a lime tree and not an avocado tree?
What a fucking jerk off.
So,
um,
I got to make sure I,
uh,
I handle that.
Oh Great.
Why is it reloading?
What is going on here?
Um,
I'm all for that though.
Growing your own food and that type of stuff and uh,
you know,
during this time I'm not not yoga man.
I'm really going to try to eat a lot less fish than I,
as much as I joke about it.
That is a serious fucking problem.
And,
uh,
I'm gonna try to,
I'm actually going to try to learn to make a couple of Vegan meals that actually
tastes good cause I'm always going to eat steak and that type of shit.
But I'm just going to try to incorporate a couple of those things because,
uh,
it keeps you in shape,
man.
It does.
And it helps you lose fucking weight.
So anyways,
um,
so that is the update.
Uh,
I wish I had a whole garden,
but I don't,
and I'm,
I'm hoping eventually I can.
I'm just hoping the water comes back here someday and if it doesn't,
I'm going to take a bath on this house.
Alrighty.
Music a bill.
My wife has great taste in music except for stuff that really sucks.
Uh,
you kind of went two ways there,
um,
of Nias music.
What group or band or a genre do you absolutely have?
Do you have absolutely no ability to swallow?
Um,
my wife has unbelievable taste in music,
uh,
particularly shit that I wouldn't be exposed to,
especially at my age of 47 year old white guy.
I'm not going to know what the latest,
you know,
even just hits are in the whole rap world.
Um,
and you guys owe me a big,
a big pat on the back there because I didn't use the expression hip hop.
I didn't want you guys to hear that coming out of my fucking mouth.
Um,
so I stay up on,
you know,
if she sees you,
always listen to some fucking,
you know,
I like to make money,
get that shit.
Got The white girl market Paula Park and follow up work.
That guy.
Um,
she let shit she listens to that,
um,
why clef rocky or whatever the fuck his name is.
Hashtag rocky moneybags dollar sign rocky.
I can't remember what his fucking name is.
She listens to a little Wayne,
uh,
Kanye,
who I can't,
I can't stand.
I listened to that guy.
He just tells me about how awesome he is and all this stuff he has.
It's excruciating.
We boring.
Um,
but he isn't,
he's not bored with himself at all.
He is absolutely amazed with how amazing he is.
Wood and God knows that's fun to listen to.
Oh yes.
By all means.
Tell me,
tell me in another verse why you're so awesome.
Um,
anyways,
you know something,
I'll tell you right now,
the stuff that,
it's not her music.
She has great,
great taste in music.
And I like,
she's one of those people that you can just grab her fucking iPhone and put it
on shuffle and just put it on in a party and nothing embarrassing comes on.
Everybody's like,
fuck,
what a song is that?
What song is that?
Like she's really up on all the good fucking music.
But um,
so anyways,
uh,
the thing that bothers me is the shit that she watches on TV.
Oh,
Jesus Christ as she watched some dumb shit,
man.
You know,
and a lot of smart women watch that reality Shit.
Evidently they like it.
And even all this smart,
it's like,
you know,
I guess it's like me watching sports.
Hang on one second.
The companies who are going to close the door,
hold on,
hang on,
hang on.
So anyways,
she watches all those uh,
fucking real housewives shows.
Okay.
But what she did recently,
and this was devastating,
what does that sound?
I thought she was talking to my wife yelling me.
She put the TV on.
This is my,
my wife bought Kim Kardashian.
I'm just shitting on this whole couple,
you know,
God bless him keys,
the cells at the staples center in,
she goes shopping,
whatever the fuck she does.
Right.
God bless both of them continued success.
MMM.
She,
she,
Kim Kardashian put out this book.
Okay.
In all the whole book is nothing but her selfies.
She pulled out a book of selfies of herself.
Not like a bunch of people taking selfies.
That would have been bad enough but it was,
it's all pictures of her and the cover of it is her just standing there with
their arms extended out,
you know,
taking a picture with the pouty lips in her hair,
all wet and
okay.
I,
you know,
you know that overly used expression like you know,
this marks the beginning of the end of civilization as we know it.
I hate when people say that.
Alright cause nothing does.
It's a gradual decline.
All right.
It's just another step.
But that thing there,
if ever I was going to say like I get really got,
I got depressed.
When I look at it,
it makes me,
it gives me this awful feeling.
When I look at it,
I can't describe it.
It's just like that I feel like there's a shift in,
uh,
just human behavior.
I don't know what it is,
but,
um,
cleal relax.
It's fine.
You don't have to eat anybody.
It's a company.
I'm sorry I fucking dogs had it's God damn ears up.
MMM.
So whenever I see it,
the key,
I always walked by and I always turn it over because on the back that's just
writing of like,
you know,
I guess recommendations that all of a selfie books,
I'll tell you this little really,
I just can't imagine
anybody has taken enough selfie stead.
It could fill up a fucking book and that you would think that someone would want
to buy it and then somebody does and then you're married to it.
It's just,
it's,
and my wife had met.
She goes,
I know,
I know.
It's so bad.
It's so bad by can't look away.
I was like,
but there's just,
I think that feeds into their,
you know,
wanting to be princesses and pretty and dressing up and getting ideas on how to
fucking,
you know,
show off their tits and a new fucking way.
I have no idea what it is.
But um,
I would say that that is it,
that I'm actually getting depressed now.
I don't if he could hear it,
my voice just talking about it
like more trees were cut down.
It's like they like a meeting like okay your guys like which one of these is
going to be the cover?
We have to figure out what is worthy of the cover.
Okay.
Which ones?
What is the photo like they had a pic like,
like pace it
like,
like which Selfie it goes on the cover,
which is the first one that opens the book,
which is,
you know,
you want to start strong,
the same way they get your tea.
We had to tell a story with these photos,
like there was fucking human being sitting there thinking about that shit.
And then they pitched the idea and somebody said yes,
and then they made it.
And then my wife bought it and it's in my fucking house.
And I swear to God
if,
if it wouldn't do like major damage to my relationship,
I would throw it in the fireplace.
I,
and she's had it on the coffee table.
She had an underneath the TV and she had downstairs on top of her dresser.
And each time I fucking turned it over like it was this built that I didn't want
to deal with it.
And um,
I would say it's that her music taste is un fucking believable
and she truly is one of the greatest people I've ever met.
That's why I fucking married her.
But,
uh,
you know,
we all got our stuff,
you know what I mean?
I sit there and I watch sports and I scream about it and I get mad.
I,
I'm trying to be empathetic and saying that that's just as fucking stupid.
MMM.
But I don't think it is.
I really don't that fucking self help book of Selfies,
not self help.
Whatever the fuck it is was a,
I had to walk that one off a hydro.
Really just be like,
okay,
yeah,
we're married and this is,
this is,
I know this isn't doesn't mean anything about her,
but Jesus fucking Christ.
It's more the influence of that that's going to influence somebody.
The white boy,
when I saw great comedians,
I wanted to be a comedian.
There's like,
I dunno,
I guess horrors need to be inspired to write that there.
I want to be the next Kim Kardashian.
I got to take,
start taking fucking self help self.
Why don't keep saying self-help selfies of myself.
You know what?
I'm glad you asked me that because I probably bumped all you guys out,
you know,
depressed you about all the fucking,
uh,
the goddamn a fishing out the oceans.
So it serves me right that you guys asked me a question that makes me feel bad.
Um,
anyways,
getting married.
Finance question.
Hey Billy galaxy,
my lady and I are getting married in two weeks.
Good field,
man.
The lover.
That's the greatest fucking move you're ever gonna make.
Um,
I never thought I'd say this.
I actually love being married.
I like going out doing my spots.
I like coming directly home.
I like being in bed by 11.
Just fucking great.
Now that I'm not boozing,
like getting up,
I'm losing weight.
I will tell you though.
Oh my God,
I'm only a weekend.
I drive by billboards and I just see a frosty fucking mug of beer.
I'm just like,
dude,
I want 50 of those.
I want fucking 50 of those.
I'm one of those guys.
I'm never going to just not drink.
There's no fucking way.
I like it too much.
I'm not addicted to it.
I just fucking love it.
I can't wait for these fucking 72 days to get over so I can fuck my liver up
again.
I fucking love it.
And I,
and I am not ashamed to say it.
Oh,
I'm not slapping around my wife.
I'm not screaming at children.
I get shit faced in my own fucking home or I go out and Obama happy drunk,
you know,
I'm happy fucking drunk.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's really helping me to count down the days rather than the go up.
So,
cause to me to sit there and think I'm a day number seven and I'm trying to get
to 72 is fucking brutal.
But if I look at it the other way and say,
hey,
65 more days,
for some reason it's like when I'm on a treadmill,
I'd rather count down from 60 minutes then start at one.
I don't know why.
That's how my brain works.
What are you going to do for me?
So anyway,
we can do for me.
What do you going,
what do you want from me?
I should have said,
all right,
my lady and I are getting married two weeks.
All is great.
Very excited.
Yadaa fucking Yada.
We both have good jobs each making about 125 grand a year in Chicago.
You guys are crushing it.
Pay Down your credit cards,
save up your fucking money and buy something that you can live in and kicked the
shit out of the principal.
All right?
Have your money work for you.
You aren't it,
it should work for you.
My question is,
what advice do you have for us regarding how to share in the finances moving
forward?
Do we keep separate accounts?
One joint account for bills?
Maybe have nia weigh in on this.
Um,
yeah,
I never did the joint account thing.
If you're going to do the joint account thing,
like you're really,
um,
you're really taking a risk there because at any moment,
especially in the Midwest,
you know,
your partner can get addicted to meth.
Okay.
And don't even fucking roll your eyes at me cause I do road gigs and I know
where the meth before and after fucking billboards are.
You get out in the Midwest and,
uh,
you know,
you drive through Iowa,
you drive through Wyoming.
I know.
Maybe not in fucking,
I dunno.
I,
I think that I'm a,
I'm a fan of,
um,
separate accounts because a,
I understand money and I don't blow it.
And I invested as wisely as I possibly can except for my drinking habits and,
uh,
my hobbies.
But,
uh,
I,
that would be up to you.
It'd be up to my,
uh,
one of my,
one of my relatives got married and uh,
he said that was really freaky at first and then,
then it was cool.
I don't think it's a big deal.
Like I trust my wife to combine accounts and all that type of shit to be honest
with you.
We just have it,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
but that's something that,
uh,
okay,
that you guys should probably talk about.
But I would say if she's not bringing it up,
I wouldn't bring it up either.
And if she does bring it up,
be like,
yeah,
hey,
why don't we sit down and talk about that and just have a serious conversation
going?
Like,
all right,
this is a tremendous,
tremendous responsibility for me.
I always put it on yourself so the listener will actually listen.
All right?
Don't come out and be like,
Hey,
fuck good shit dick.
You know,
I don't want you fucking spending my money.
Don't look at,
don't come coming on now.
Cause they'll shut down and get defensive.
You got to come at him like this.
Just be like,
this is a huge responsibility.
I want you to know this is a huge responsibility from me,
which then she'll have to say,
well,
it's a huge responsibility for me to write.
You'll get her to say that you'll have her on tape saying that and just say,
listen,
you know,
as much as we're married and we're combining our accounts,
I respect the money that you're bringing into the account and I want you to know
that I would never,
okay.
Like go out and buy either something sizable or a bunch of knickknacks that
ended up being sizeable chunk out of the fucking account out of respect for how
hard you work.
Okay.
And really sit down and talk about money,
talk about how you want to win fest it,
learn about money and all that type of shit.
Um,
so you don't end up like one of these people who puts the money in there and you
think everything's fucking fine and then they're there.
Yeah,
they got a credit card that they're fucking lighten up and then they attach to
your fucking,
I dunno what it's one bank account.
And they go,
well you got the money in there and Sunday your name,
we want our 15 fucking grand in seven,
eight of that grant is yours.
And that goes flying out the window because she bought a bunch of blobs and,
and choose and this shit can happen.
All right.
And I'm speaking from the male perspective because I am a guy and that doesn't
make me as sexist.
Okay.
You know,
I've been thinking a lot about these fucking groups by the way,
how it is dope to join a group and why it's doomed for failure.
A lot of times it's because once you join a group that has a cause,
you basically go into this think tank where everybody basically shares the same
point of view.
So you don't have anybody keeping in check on like,
well yeah I don't know about that.
Or Hey,
you know,
you installed them low bed a little bit insulted them.
So it's like,
it becomes like when to conspiracy theories meet each other.
And,
you know,
conspiracy theorist needs somebody to be sitting there going like,
dude,
do you really think are all I dude,
you know,
I was with you until then.
But if two conspiracy theorist meet each other,
they just a dude,
you know what else?
Oh yeah.
You know what I heard?
And they just fucking,
they just go right down the rabbit hole.
And I think a lot of times why when I listened to like a lot of the feminists
complaining,
it strikes me as funny because so much of the shit that they're bitching about,
I relate to.
It's like,
yeah,
that's happened to me.
That is also happened to me.
20% of it.
Yeah,
I'll go with it.
that's fucked up.
You know?
But just know that even if you got on par with guys,
you still staring at an 80% fuck over.
That's the best I can give you.
Is that sexist?
If it is,
I don't give a fuck.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I can't get over that Ford Galaxy man.
That is exactly what the fuck I'm looking for.
Here's another great one.
2,500 bucks.
Now he's two door.
Let's see what we got here.
Oh Geez.
Is a bunch of parts laying around.
This is my shit.
Oh,
tears.
I'll tell you a little bit rough.
You know.
[inaudible] is too rough.
God dammit.
What's the engine looking like?
Yeah,
that's all good shit.
All right,
hang on,
let me get a look at the last one.
Jesus Christ.
Andrew,
you crushed it with these.
Um,
all right,
this is,
is it really interesting to have you guys looking at car listening to me,
looking at cars that they can't fucking see.
Uh,
my is another guy in 1998.
[inaudible] 68,
sorry,
couple years off there.
Um,
I dunno,
kind of getting into that,
I'm going to stick with the 65 though.
65 is bad ass.
Okay.
Um,
here I go again.
I'm doing this shit again.
So anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Once again,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast and a 10% of the proceeds will go to the
Saint Jude hospital is a,
anytime you go on Amazon,
just go to Amazon through my website,
which is basically built [inaudible] dot com and you click on the merchant page,
then you click on the Amazon link.
It doesn't cost you any extra money.
And they just kicked me a little bit of cash for a driving traffic their way.
Um,
other than that,
that is the podcast for this week.
All right,
everybody,
you got to lose three pounds a week with me over the next eight weeks.
Huh?
Get on the fucking scale today or is it starts tomorrow?
How about that?
All right,
we'll start tomorrow because you didn't know it was happening,
right?
So it starts tomorrow.
Go to the grocery store tonight.
He gets your old meal,
he gets your bananas,
your apple,
your orange,
whatever the fuck you want.
You get your Turkey slices or whatever fucking meat you want.
Um,
your fucking salads,
one giant salad a day and then at night just get that protein.
Even go vegan every once in a while at night.
And then do you know what to take a walk around the block?
You,
you have no idea what that would do.
Hey Nia.
Hey Baby.
Hey,
really quickly.
Uh,
somebody wanted you to chime in on one of these fucking questions.
This is so stupid.
Why would I do,
oh,
it does.
Well,
maybe,
maybe you can do it next week.
Right here.
Um,
all right.
I'm not going to ask you a Clia watch out.
Are you going to shut the fucking recorder off?
All right.
Okay.
Hey,
people ask me,
they said they asked,
um,
of knee as music.
What group or band or John,
right?
Do you have absolutely no ability to swallow?
And I said none.
I said you had this,
you have great taste in music that you,
you're actually one of those few people that you can put your phone on shuffle
at a party and you're not embarrassed.
However,
sit down.
Stop trying to divide and conquer.
There you go.
Why?
Oh,
there's going to work because the one thing that I,
the one thing I can't stomach.
And what's that?
The Kim Kardashians Selfie book.
Like the cover that right?
Oh yeah.
No I got that book and I have no shame.
I've participated in all levels of pop culture.
So if anybody has something to say,
no I'm saying it.
Nobody else is saying you are saying I can you do me a favor with that book.
What?
You can lay it out anytime you want.
Just you always turn it over.
Have the cupboard turned over cause it's okay.
That depresses me.
Why
I just,
I can't even put it into fucking like if you can,
why?
Cause I just feel like there's this,
now this,
this,
I just hate her.
I just can't stand her.
I don't hate her.
But like why though?
Why are people so bothered?
Cause cause they're like constantly shoved down our throats.
No,
the fleet
narcissist.
Oh yeah.
And the,
the fact that I,
you know,
the six dead,
whole fucking famous for being famous.
You don't really do anything.
You came into your fucking suck the Dick.
You became famous.
The family got behind it like,
yeah,
my daughter's sucks.
The Best Dick and fucking Calabasas.
It wasn't quite like that,
but,
okay.
All right.
How,
okay.
I am sure they had an honorable way of parlaying that whatever.
What I'm,
I'm trying not to be judgmental.
God Far.
She sucked a dick.
She got famous and now she's got a selfie book and she's sitting there.
Dude,
it is just so
like,
so.
I,
when I went to get it,
I was surprised that it was sold out at this very independent and a hip section
of La.
It was out.
They were like,
oh,
it's sold out as soon as we got it.
This has nothing to do with other people.
This has to do with me.
It's about you.
I'm sorry,
go on.
Just saying,
you're asking me why it depresses me.
Those fucking people.
When I watch somebody take a selfie rather than just,
I'm,
look,
I stand from the Hollywood sign,
you click on whatever,
but when people hold it up over their head and then it turned their head trying
to fucking look better looking than they are.
And sticking your lips out.
The duck loves is Babel.
Why wouldn't you try to look as good as possible in a picture that you're taking
of yourself?
That's what's so great about the Selfie is that you can really see what angle
looks best and with the lighting is,
I think it's,
it's,
it makes a lot of sense.
Logically to me it's,
it makes perfect sense to adjust yourself before you just take a picture.
Does this like that?
No.
I want to make sure that I'm looking right.
That's the whole point.
Why are you,
why do you look confused?
You know what?
I am old enough to know that I'm not going to convince you otherwise,
so God bless you and the Selfie me if you can,
can you,
can we have a compromise?
You just turn the book over.
I will just keep it somewhere where it's not in your line of vision.
Since you're so offended by it.
I'm not offended by it.
It just,
it depresses me to look at it.
Well,
I don't want to depress you.
I'm,
how would I be condescending?
Just,
okay,
go on.
Just just get out of here.
I won't,
I'll keep it out of your sight.
I'll keep it out of your side.
Okay.
Are you writing that down right now?
No ma'am.
Do you want to tell the the caffeinated not the caffeinated story?
I would.
Can we save that for a
checking in on you?
Yes.
Cause I gotta go get out of here because I can wrap this up.
Internet sucks here and this will take me four hours to fucking upload.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
On Thursday.
I will tell you guys the story of
the,
uh,
decaffeinated not to caffeinated.
Uh,
you know,
I fucked up.
I fucked up getting this tea with my wife and she's did,
she tried to say I wasn't listening and I actually was listening,
but
I thought
to caffeinated,
not to caffeinated.
I thought that that's what the two flavors were.
MMM.
Well,
it's a long fucking story.
All right.
That was confusing.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
And a God bless all of you.
Go take some selfies.
You know,
put out your fucking,
then you do the little peace sign too.
Like whatever that's for,
you know,
like you're out,
even though you're not in my life.
Um,
um,
I know I'm just a crabby old man.
I'll go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you.
I'll check in on you.